okay thank you very much for that
introduction and for having me here
today um I'm I've done a few iterations
of this talk and um it's always
generated really good discussion at the
end so I encourage you to have any
questions um ready if you want to talk
either in the talk or after in um one
one-on-one sessions um and I actually I
also restructured these this talk
because I realized that many of the fols
in the mentorship Stream are not just
maybe new entrance like breaking into
Tech but might be transitioning from
previous careers or even different lines
of tech um so I hope that my suggestions
here um will be able to speak to all
levels of experiences and different
career
paths okay
so um before I get into it this is what
I'm hoping to be covering today I'll
first talk about a motivation for why
even bother writing online um
then we'll dive into personal examples
that I've used in how I've use writing
online to network more effectively and
interview in a less stressful way um and
then we'll turn to okay how do we
actually do this what is a writing
strategy look like for those of us who
don't like to write who have a fear of
writing um or who maybe just like find
it very stressful to write don't have
time to write we'll cover all those
scenarios um and then towards the end
we'll talk about some of the last smild
features that we often neglect when we
are writing a piece to publish online to
share with other
people all right so um a bit about me um
I this is my journey on the left I did a
data science boot camp way back in 2019
and then I graduated into the covid job
market it was like perfectly timed I
think it was March or April 20 20 um and
I was very fortunate to land at towards
data science which some of you might
know is as a medium
publication um for data science data
engineering machine learning
articles and um after that I moved to a
sales engineer role at plotly see on the
right here uh this was one of the few
times I met my colleagues in person
because by that point so many of us had
gone uh remote permanently I took a
short break for graduate school last
year and but over the um year and a half
that I've been at school and now working
I've turned to freelance consultant um
in technical writing for a variety of
companies in data engineering and data
science you might recognize some of them
they include uh dagster the
orchestration tool plotly my old
employer um a data fold data diffing
with DPT um and a few others that I
can't name right
now some of my work has been published
online for example I wrote this 10p part
series for Daxter um on python guide
specifically for the data engineer to
help onboard them they're coming from
other languages or other
tools okay so let's jump into it um why
write online um I think it most people
find it really hard to get started I
personally do as well I do not have an
active blog I don't have a substack I
don't Advocate having one I just have a
few good really good pieces online that
helped me get started I think actually I
only have one piece um that I had online
like four years ago uh to launch my
career and that's really all you need
you don't need like to be an influencer
on Linkin um or do anything more
involved in that um but let me share an
anecdote from my T data science days um
when I was working at fors data science
um part of my job required vetting
article submissions and to do that we
use a variety of uh factors for example
it was not just whether your article was
good it was you know does the data set
that you use respect um you know open
source uh uh rules you know is it a
proprietary data set we need to get
permissions for um are your
visuals engaging and catchy do they make
sense um but we also assess whether the
authors have any education
uh or professional
credibility and one time when I was
going back and forth with a colleague on
you know this article seems good but you
know I'm really not sure and I can't
seem to find info about this this author
online um she made this com comment this
author barely seems to exist and I
thought that was a perfect description
for what you don't want to happen many
times we encountered LinkedIn profiles
that look like this
um it's not public to a stranger um
there's barely any information even in
the title of what they do um and these
authors were required to link their
their profiles in their submissions form
so um there there was not much thought
as to you know what we were going to see
when we clicked on that link and it
probably hurts a lot of people's
professional credibilities to leave
LinkedIn profiles like
that I follow um this Tech influencer
you could call I'm sure many of you have
heard of him too Patrick McKenzie uh who
previously worked for straight um and he
is one of the internet's most prolific
writers and is an example of how a
software engineer can be a really good
writer um in a way that also creates a
lot of career
leverage um I I couldn't find the exact
same exact tweet that I saw which made
me think about um putting a talk
together in the first place but he he
talked about how writing online serves
as one of the biggest Roi you can have
for your
career there's a pretty good chance that
you will be Googled before your
interview or even in a networking
setting someone will look you up after a
conference they've met met you at they
want to learn more about you um and it's
a having some sort of Polished Work
online is a great way to Signal your
technical
chops it also indicates that you're
conscientious um that you've made an
effort to present yourself uh
professionally to your peers and I think
this is something that many of Us in
Industry underestimate we focus too much
on the GitHub repos the git commits and
not about everything that comes
alongside
that so I'm going to show you how this
works to supercharge your networking and
interviewing before I tell you how to do
it I'm trying to take my own advice here
in that you know I want to show you the
good stuff UPF front before I get into
the meat of like how you actually get it
done okay okay so networking networking
is a very scary word networking is
really hard and it's quite frankly even
harder online um so when I graduated
into the covid job market um all the
in-person conferences that all like
disappeared right and as a fresh grad
it's like how am I going to meet
connections who will be able to refer me
um to Vanishing job
opportunities um so it made me think
about what a a credible strategy would
look like um and so my advice here would
really apply to both iners and and
online situations it's for both um
because the problem of networking is
establishing trust with someone you've
just met right and it's the same whether
you meet them at a conference for the
first time um and you try to give
yourself a give them a 30- second Pitch
on who you are and why you're great to
talk to and why they should follow up
with you um and it's even more true when
you're sending out maybe tens of
LinkedIn requests every day trying to
reach someone at a company that you're
applying for or even just to learn more
about their career path and get some
advice and mentorship on like what you
should do
next so you can think of your writing as
doing two things it serves as an
icebreaker and it also serves as a
credible signal of what you can
do so I found this funny image um that
really plays to both of these uh writing
features right um many of us suffer from
imposter syndrome um that that's
especially true if we trying to move
into a new industry or a new role for
the first time and it's like it's kind
of a stretch to say oh you know what
I've done this program that means that I
can be a data scientist um but writing
can help you make that jump a bit um
more cred
right and it also serves as a hey like
I've done something this is something we
can talk about right now we don't have
to just make small talk about the
weather and then move
on so I want to share a few examples of
what I mean when I as I think a lot of
these how to network online or inperson
articles or advice columns you see out
there um they don't really get to like
how does that actually work so I'm going
to show you like screenshots from my own
personal life because I feel like that
might be really helpful
so oftentimes you can say like imagine
you're sending an email um or you're
sending like a link LinkedIn request or
a Twitter DM and I've done like all
three to land like gigs um you could say
hi I'm interested in a 15minute chat
with you about your experience at say
Microsoft that's not super interesting
if people get a lot of these requests
every day they're getting a lot of spam
and they're likely to just like you know
what I'm busy why should I give this
person the time of
day even worse I find that the the
advice to go around asking people for
referrals um is like people have to
stake their reputation to refer you
internally for positions that's a pretty
big ask if they don't know you very
well so what I found is that if you
include a link to what you've done
saying hey I actually just did worked on
this great project doesn't matter if it
was a side project or a real project you
did like at a company you say I built
this model to improve this outcome and
you can check it out online here if you
like oftentimes people will say okay
well there's a link I'll click on it and
see what's up they'll still have to
assess you to be whether see whether
you're credible um but it's it lends
more organically to a follow-up
interaction they could say hey that's
really cool um but I'm not I'm not in
that industry I don't think that would
be much of help that's totally possible
as an outcome um but they could also say
um oh that's really cool um here's my
Kenly feel free to book a call and we
can we can discuss more of your interest
or how I can help
you here are also two more examples um
of how networking is easier when you
have proof of work uh these are as you
can see by the time stamps the is right
when Co hit um so on the left it was an
email that I sent to uh a recruiter
right after I spoke with them at um an
online uh conference it says TMS Booth
it was an online conference by that
point um and I think it was one of those
like uh Zoom style conversations where
they just pair you up randomly with
people and I just quickly got the name
and I was like okay I'll follow up them
um having something published already
helped me craft a more substantive email
to follow up um I could say I I recently
did this this is my proof of work um is
there anyone I could talk to at your
company to discuss more
opportunities same similar example on
the right uh I think I was following it
with the personent Shopify um yeah so
you can fit a lot into those LinkedIn um
I think it's like 300 character limits
for a cold Outreach note um and then
just leave it leave it for the other
person to take a look
at one of the Articles so that same
article that I've linked now multiple
times again like I'm not lying when I
said I only hit one article um this was
an article I did for the boot camp that
I was in and I I tagged I wrote the
article I tagged the organization that
we had done our co-op with and they were
really helpful in retweeting um
and providing some commentary which you
know helps to provide some level of
social proof that you know Elliott isn't
this totally random person who's like
doesn't know what he's talking about
this is validated by a third party
organization um and as well as the staff
at that
organization um yeah and also I don't
tweet so like this is the extent of all
the tweeting that happens for
me all right so writing is also really
helpful for interviewing and I bow it
down to like three
reasons um writing helps you discuss
what really matters I found this on
LinkedIn uh recently and I thought it
was just like the perfect encapsulation
of what I mean by this um so this person
says give this answer to the question
how can you evaluate a candidate's
domain knowledge during data research
interviews um so notice that towards the
end they talk about how um they Grill
candidates on detailing the tools data
sources and libraries they employed and
their reasons for doing so this is to
help determine whether the candidate
truly grasp the underlying Concepts that
they've engaged with so it's not merely
about did you ship a project but did you
understand why you picked certain tools
what were the what were the constraints
that you had to deal with along the way
um and do you understand maybe the
Alternatives that you could the
alternative paths that you can taken um
and oftentimes during an interview you
know these interviews will start
drilling down to try to get a sense of
like did did you really do this did you
really do you really understand this um
it's not just about how shiny your web
application looks or or how great it
sounds on paper but what knowledge you
actually
have and so writing forces you to
understand the entire code base that
you've done the methodological
assumptions the modeling tradeoffs and
so
on it's also really great interview PR
because once you have this down on paper
in whether it's online or internally
somewhere um you can reference it
quickly right before an interview um
which is really helpful when there's a
huge gap between say your last
substantive project and your next role
um and this has definitely saved me many
times uh because over the course of your
career you know you're probably not
going to be working on Amazing projects
every week there'll be a couple of a
handful of projects that where you feel
like really impacted the company's
bottom line you've had a significant
contribution to the codebase um and
that's something that you know is a
great example of your skill set so
having it down helps you not forget all
the incredible things that you did until
that
point a question that I often get is how
do you deal with uh Team projects and
your own individual
contributions um I think that writing
online helps you cite step the entire
question because if you have to write
about a project you have to know all the
movie pieces right whether you wrote the
code for that or you didn't um you need
to understand how it all fits together
and that's especially true in say data
engineering data science where you can't
just write about like the model that you
iterated on but about you know what
databases you pulled it into what was
your ETL uh
framework um what was the frontend UI
you guys used for whether it was a
notebook um or a web application like
Dash
um so obviously you don't want to lie
about your personal contributions to a
project but being able to talk
intelligently about all the different
areas and say hey if you want to ask me
about this feature I actually know where
this is in the codebase and I can talk
about it um and demonstrating that
signal of you're not just good at one
thing but like you understand a project
holistic
all right
so oh one more thing about interviewing
um writing makes it easy to follow up on
job interviews in a meaningful way um
oftentimes people will say oh after
you've had an interview you should
follow up with the recruiter or whoever
you talk to right um I'm not sure how
useful that advice is but generally it's
probably safer to air on the side of
like being being polite and
proactive um but just following up in an
interview by saying thank you for your
time isn't really that significant it
doesn't really help you stand out when
they're having candidates that are quite
close
together you could follow up more
meaningfully if you say hey I enjoyed
our conversation and I wanted to share
some links to the two projects that we
discussed on the call so here I add the
two projects and again both of these
projects I did during my boot camp so it
doesn't have to be something crazy that
you're doing from
scratch all right so let's now talk
about a writing strategy for
non-writers um you don't have to love
writing to write one great article and
I'm pretty adamant about this you only
need one article you don't need a Blog
you don't need a substack um you can
just write that one article and never
publish again that's probably fine um
and so the strategy that I've come up
with hopefully will help simplify the
process for you
so it proceeds in three parts you have
your documentation you have a writing
structure and then you have some stuff
at the
end uh on making sure it's really tight
and
Punchy so um so the project that I
talked about you know the one article
that I keep referencing was this uh
project that we did on using very simple
machine learning methods to identify
instance es of trade fraud in a real
trade data set um so on the left this
was my group that we were assigned at to
work on this project in conjunction with
e think tank in the states um and on the
right was the outcome of the project in
which I took leadership of writing up
the project um and we were fortunate in
that although no one else on the team
were writers we took extens notes I
think we had more than 20 pages of
documentation on every single step of
the way from data cleaning to data
processing to you know how we pull data
into um out of parquette files um how we
cleaned very very messy uh trade data um
with foreign language uh that that none
of us spoke Russian um and how we dealt
with you know false positives and things
like that so when it came time to write
almost three months later uh I could
refer back to that docu document and
proceed section by section to write
cleaner copy
on what what we did for every single
step of the
way so it's much easier to write up a
thousand-word blog post or even
something shorter um in this way because
you will absolutely forget everything by
the time a project ends um so document
everything you can um even if you think
it was a really trivial decision at the
time the second way to do this is to
proceed with a structure um you don't
have to reinvent the wheel for a lot of
writing and it is okay to be really
boring so if you think about research
articles they often have you know they
have the abstract they have keywords
they have the intro we talk about data
collection feature engineering um then
there's stuff about methodology and then
like future directions for further
research right
um I advise doing the exact same thing
so you don't have to follow my suggested
structure here this is what I found to
be helpful and which covered all my
bases in an article and um if any of you
have used uh libraries like um cookie
cutter where you know you pip install it
into your data science project and it
builds out all your files and folder
structure so you can get to work right
away think about this as
um that but for your writing projects so
you copy paste this into your word doc
make these all headers and then you just
get to work 300 words for each section
and then you're
done I want to highlight though I put
here that methodology is
optional I think that as chat GPT
becomes um a better better way to I
guess create writing fast good writing
fast this part is going to be more and
more critical for writing any any sort
of
writing because it demonstrates um a
sense of the context in which you built
a project whether that was a side
project or within a large organization
where you had to talk about talk about
like competing resources constraints
time things like that um the methodology
section is where you can really expand
into context sensitive information that
is really interesting to recruiters and
future employers right
um you know there's like many tools
right now that can run machine learning
uh models on your data uh intelligently
automatically automl whatever you want
to call it um but those tools don't take
into consideration the specific context
that you're in and there's often a lot
of tweaking
um involved before you get to
production this is where you can shine
and I and I think increasingly this
should not be
optional um some other helpful tips um
so you probably are familiar with the
famous statistic that recruiters only
spend 7 seconds on a resume um I don't
know how true that is but I think that's
true for articles uh there's there's so
much to read online like I find it very
difficult to keep up with new WR new
really good writing I have so much
bookmarked in my Twitter uh in my Google
Chrome tab um I have so many substacks
that I subscribe to to keep up with the
industry it's really helpful to make
your article information dense make
every sentence count don't feel like you
have to fill up the work count um longer
doesn't mean better it's okay to get to
the
point it's also really helpful to have
lots of visual
that are
significant um you want something that
can illustrate a core finding that you
found a conclusion or an assumption that
you debunked or
validated um oftentimes people as
they're reading an article they're kind
of jumping back and forth they're like
skimming the top skim the bottom then
they'll look at the visual and be like
okay I should dig into this a bit more
to see how they dealt with this problem
so the visual can often be a really
important hook to get them to
continue you also want to include code
to demonstrate your technical skills um
but I would advise keeping it short
right because if people want to
replicate your project or dive deeper
they'll look at your GitHub they'll try
it they'll test it locally um they they
will hunt for the information themselves
the Snippets are to Showcase something
clever you did uh to solve a problem
like how did you process this extremely
large data set um in memory uh with this
cool tool you can use GitHub gist for
this GitHub gists are great because they
exist online on your profile uh
independent of the article and then you
can copy paste that gist multiple times
like on your own personal website or a
medium
article you'll also want a really strong
and descriptive specific
title I got a lot of these examples from
articles that I saved um I think I think
these are actual articles um that I
found and if you're stuck on how to
actually frame it you could say again
cookie cutter method using tool data set
to build achieve improve X that's it um
chat GPT is also really great for coming
in with ideas for how you should best
title something lots of companies also
include uh their own engineering blogs
where they where you can kind of get a
feel for how the industry talks to each
other and use the same language to try
to demonstrate that you're in the know
and you're trying to Signal um I guess
High higher value
writing so again these articles seem
really boring but they get to the point
and for the right person they will not
be
boring all right so I want to talk about
the last mile um this part is often
neglected because it is is just so much
work and I feel like people also get
really perfectionist about it I'm
definitely guilty of this um you think
oh my gosh it's going to take so much
time for me to curate a consistent
professional brand
online um oftentimes you find it you
take two hours you get the essentials
done and boom you exist in a
professional
way I found it really helpful to get
professional feedback on my LinkedIn uh
my website or my res resum particularly
my resume um if you've never been able
to do this like say from a recruiter if
you I've been able to ask recruiters at
in-person conferences to be like can you
can you tell me what I should do better
about my resume like how does this
resume speak to you sometimes they will
give you good good advice right on the
spot um but if you can't try to get
someone who's been in a recruiting role
or in a managerial role to give you
advice uh because they can they can tell
you what's missing in a way that can't
because they've seen like hundreds or
thousands of these and they know what is
a good signal for um
skill on medium or any other sites that
you publish on I highly I strongly
suggest using your own personal website
it doesn't have to be fancy the pro of
having your own website is that you
don't have to worry about uh pay walls
like medium um or say the the company
goes under and your your articles are
all taken down um but it doesn't matter
if it's easier for you to get started
with a medium account do it on medium on
GitHub on all these Pages have a short
two to three sentence bio keep it
focused on your uh professional
interests and have a way for people to
connect with
you on LinkedIn this is these are things
that I've learned from T data science
and from scanning hundreds maybe even
thousands of LinkedIn profiles by this
point um it's really great to talk
about again current program if you're
studying your previous industry if
you're already working and and if
relevant you don't want to confuse
people um invitation to connect your
professional interests do not put
phrases like data Enthusiast an aspiring
data scientist I I've saw many of those
and whether the person was technically
proficient or not it served as a way to
Signal um beginner status and you don't
want to do
that have a professional photo um I know
this gets talked out about a lot you
don't need a head shot um oftentimes the
iPhone has now like portrait mode and
things like that just get your friend to
do it something outside with a nice uh
shirt on uh professional um selfies tend
to hurt it's almost better to not have a
photo I feel um and you want to why you
want to have a personality you also
don't want to waste space on your
profiles finally when you do have this
article up add it everywhere add it in
your LinkedIn bio add it in your Medan
bio like add it everywhere you can on
Twitter you got Pinn it at the top um
don't hide it make it easy for people to
find so in conclusion I only have a few
things um if you if you leave with
nothing else um this is just what I want
to leave you with um I don't want to use
stress we all have so much to do
nowadays between working full-time and
having side project
taking courses um and learning all these
new tools that are coming out every day
you really only need one or two articles
online to Signal professional
credibility and get
started boring and Technical super
underrated it's okay to get to the point
uh people love it when you
do um if you're looking for inspiration
especially if you don't feel like you're
a strong writer um and want to get
better one way to do it is to read
examples of great data science articles
and blogs you can check out substack
leaderboard for the best substacks on
data science articles um there's a
really famous analytics engineering one
to check out uh Randy 's counting stuff
substack is fantastic for talking
through methodologies and assumptions in
um data science uh but there's like
there's like a million out there uh of
like really good articles and if all
else fails just find the company's blog
I think Netflix has a really good
corporate blog oftentimes companies
curate these blogs as a way to recruit
they want to demonstrate their technical
knowhow to get the best engineering
talent and so mirroring their style and
depth is a way to also grow as a
technical
person existing online is super
important for sending a strong
professional signal get your own website
I host on GitHub pages with jaal it is a
more involved way of doing it but it's
free and it's super easy to update you
can do this with WordPress it honestly
doesn't matter you can use Wix um you
don't have to have like the perfect
template um just one article needs to
exist with a
bio fifth um try to get feedback on your
articles um if you're stuck or if you're
shy to reach out to someone chat gbt has
been a very good uh copy editor um and I
think
grammarly the plugin has been useful too
for folks to adjust like tone so you
don't want to sound too formal in uh
formal or informal you want to find like
a sweet spot of talking to your peers in
the industry um I'm always available if
you want to brainstorm or troubleshoot
problems or even like get over the fear
of writing getting started with a blank
page
um and I can give you lots of tips on
how to do that with chat
GPT so that's the end of my talk I want
to leave time for questions because I
think that's where things can get more
generative um and I'm happy to go into
more detail to on specific parts that I
talked about I've got lots of examples
that I could share as well um but again
I'm very open to collaborating on drafts
and helping you out if you have specific
career questions related to technical
writing please book a call with me um
through Ken Lee uh I think my link is
floating around on the mentorship
spreadsheet um I didn't know this was a
career path until a year ago and lots of
companies are looking for technical
writers um so happy to talk about that
and other career paths um or the
companies that I've worked with and also
feel free to connect on
LinkedIn thank
you
wow thank you
Elliot uh the floor is open for everyone
who wants to ask
question um if if we have a shy audience
and I'm like I'm always the shy person
in the talk like that's totally fine um
just DM me or we just set up a call
that's totally fine too
uh hi Elliot this is ARA sorry I'll
just oh good hi hi so no not that shy
but I don't know if it is a relevant
question so I come from an analytical
background but you know gradually I
moved into a managerial position and I
don't really want to go back to coding
but you know
the what do you call it you know the ask
off the time is like you know you need
to be conversent in talking about MLS
and uh you know llms and their
application and use cases uh I work in
people analytics domain so we do find a
lot of use and in the past two years
I've seen you know my company use a lot
of new products using ML and I consult
on those projects so I'm an advisor um
basically and you know some companies
call it uh execution consultant so you
know my my aim to learn these ml tools
and um llms uh you know codes is not
really to get hands on on it but you
know to be able to assist and advice and
also I should be able to audit work but
um you know when you talk about
technical writer I think that's that's
where I fit see a fit uh but you know
and then I don't really get it like do
you mean a technical writer has to have
a technical skill and then they have to
do the writing and you know make like
you know produce content based on their
code coding
skills um great question so I've been I
found that I've been able to write
intelligently about technical work even
if I'm not an expert in and often times
that's why a company hires one so I I do
everything from like blog posts like for
marketing blog posts uh the one I wrote
for Daxter was fairly low level right
it's like python for beginners through
white papers on where companies are
trying to sell to other companies B2B um
lately I've been doing a lot of
technical like documentation so going
into to test the product try to library
myself find uh ways to communicate the
features better and in in any none of
these situations did I need to be as
good as a software engineer um to to
contribute um now it definitely helps to
have the technical skills and I think
like that part you cannot like skip over
uh but the cool part of technical
writing is that you get the opportunity
to learn as you write uh so that you can
be a better writer right like you want
to talk about the entire stack instead
of just that one feature
um well that means that you actually
have to understand certain Concepts um
so there's there's like many many ways
to get into it you can start like more
gently through the through the beginner
level stuff or if you you feel confident
you could talk about like the
practitioner level which is what
companies really love and there's a
surprising shortage of good content for
practitioners so I don't I don't know if
that's uh answers the question technical
like advis role because I know like a
lot of companies now have a role called
you know um ml advisor or something or
you know kind of like a yeah I I don't
think that would be it
because where where the writers fit in
is they they could use the software
Engineers to talk about what they're
shipping right but software Engineers
are are very expensive and they don't
love to write they may not even write
well uh right so some companies part of
their shipping process is when Engineers
do create a new a new feature they have
to add documentation but the
documentation is not great so you go in
and you clean it up you're like actually
we could communicate this so much better
and you know what we could create a
whole blog post series on this new
feature so you're thinking like
editorial strategy you're thinking
marketing strategy um you're trying to
think how do I add value to the company
without just creating SEO
optimized horrible blog posts right how
do I actually add value here in this
industry yeah so it's it's a very fluid
role and I think it's a huge spectrum of
what technical writing can be but I
think really good technical writing adds
value to
practitioners so how do you get into
that field so basically when you said
technical writing you can start you know
smaller or you can be really you know
technical person and then the what the
companies like so if you want to grow
gradually what should be the right way
to do
it so okay I'll I'll give two scenarios
so one is that say you're working at a
company as an analytics engineer or a
software engineer and you want to you
want to try you could get gigs on the
side you could freelance for other
companies as long as they're not in
conflict or you could start writing
internally for your company um often
times the marketing department in a
business is underresourced
and they don't know what to write about
they don't have the technical skills
right so they're they're getting they're
getting ideas from looking what their
competitors are doing but if you as the
software engineer come in like hey um I
I see this problem that we face with our
clients a lot this would be a really
good blog post to signal that we solved
it um and it's not been written well
about enough like I I would I want to do
that for you it's it's free work for
them the marketing department is like oh
my gosh we love you please please do
this for us um and then you get your
name out there on the company's
blog um so it's basically is targeting
company
blogs and that's how you get that you
know I think that's the easiest path
yeah that's the easiest path because
like company blogs there's a lot more
flexibility as to what you can write
about if you want to do like white
papers and stuff for a company
oftentimes maybe they already have a
team there's like a product manager
involved things like that their Turf um
blogs are a quicker way to help
marketing teams um but if like if you
wanted to do it like as a standalone
career uh it it helps to start building
a
portfolio I I think that's honestly the
only way to do it you need a portfolio
that's how I got started and then as you
get stronger uh you you start to
demonstrate different skills and people
start referring you okay got it yeah got
it so I don't have to be totally into
you know moving into a technical ml
engineering role but I can still you
know kind of do smaller versions of code
Snippets and then create blog spots okay
that I think that is more like me uh I
think I wouldn't really want to convert
into a full-time engineering role or you
know just be around the system and sit
in one place you know more like person
who would like to express more uh you
know write more or talk more with the
stakeholders like so I think uh that the
second the third option is a better one
for me oh yes yes absolutely I'm I'm not
the most technical person um my job is
like 70% writing 30% technical the
technical piece is how I continue to
stay sharp and understand the product
deeply but I I'm I would guess that
there are people on this call like way
stronger python coders than me yeah and
that's okay like you don't it's it's
about comparative advantage
thank you I think that answers my
question thank thanks that's a great
question yeah um thank you thank you for
that yeah uh do you mind if I connect
with you on LinkedIn and then if I have
any questions I can just ping you okay
thank you yes I I really mean that I
think people don't take advantage of
invitations to connect enough online and
many of my uh career
referrals um have come from just Co
coffee Chats on Zoom you know people
remember you they think oh that guy he
was looking for a job in this industry
um I'll tell him about this internal
posting uh that actually happened to me
a month ago um so like I strongly
recommend everyone just call like this
is an underutilized resource to to to
have copy chats with people
online yeah that's that's a good uh you
know advice for everyone I get thank you
welcome um are there uh any any other
questions
uh yes there there are questions the
there some in the chat oh okay sorry I
will uh look at the
chat um okay
so uh so the question on a generic
blogging site or build your own website
um yeah great question so I would say do
whatever is a lower barrier to getting
it started um it took me two years to
get my website up because I kept
thinking oh like I I need to like pick
the perfect template and I need to
figure out my file like my website
structure and I need to have a proper
head shot and all this these things and
then when I finally did it it like took
me like an afternoon to get up and
obviously like since then I've been
iterating on it and adding to it every
day um but whatever you think you can
get up in an afternoon is the best path
because you can always upgrade later on
uh but it's better to have like a link
now now to start adding and handing out
to
people um I've also noticed that in a
lot of company like uh application forms
they have now added like oh do you have
uh your own website to add to the link
in addition to your GitHub repo your
LinkedIn profile and your Twitter
profile U so so recruiters are
definitely like looking through these
things to see um get get a sense of who
are you beyond the onepage resume and
cover letter right it's it's a holistic
view of how you
operate yeah so I hope I answer that
question um but yeah use GitHub Pages
because it's free and links to your
GitHub oh yes okay so the question by
Matt on transitioning to a path towards
devell yes that is a great question um
and I can speak to that now because in
the last month I've been interviewing
for devell positions um I've turned them
down because ultimately they weren't the
right fit for me
but in hindsight um there was there was
a a lot of the skills that a technical
writer uses overlaps with Dev uh
developer relations so for those of you
who don't know um developer relations is
like jobs like developer Advocates
they're very public right they they're
the ones maybe shaping the blog content
they're doing talks they're they're
posting on link in about the company's
products uh specifically for other
developers and so they demonstrate all
the skills that technical technical
writer needs except they need to be
public facing as well um and I think as
a technical writer you can choose the
degree to which you want to be the face
of the company like some stuff I ghost
write my name is not attached to it
often times be white papers and stuff uh
blog post sometimes my name will be on
it sometimes not um documentation
definitely like your name won't be on it
in any in any way so you can put be
pretty like quiet underneath the surface
um or if you like tweeting and talking
to an audience and you're not shy to
speak to folks in person or online like
absolutely this would build your
portfolio towards developer relations um
and then if you're more ambitious you
can create like a newsletter with some
consistency to build readership and
companies sometimes like to see that oh
you built an audience and we want your
audience we want to bring you in house
um so yeah so that that would be my two
cents on that that career path I hope
that's useful but please feel free to
have any followup
questions um if anyone's looking for a
developer relations role kestra is
hiring right now if um you know KRA is a
data orchestration
company and they have one of the uh
industry's best technical writers there
she is her name is Anna Geller um she's
written a lot online the last few years
um she's now a product manager
there uh there is a question in the
Q&A okay yeah do you have access to it
or I just oh yeah I don't have access to
it would you mind uh reading it okay it
says do you ever get get negative
feedback when you message when you
message someone with a link to an
article you have
written I am concerned it would come off
as entitled because the person might
feel you are giving
them work to
do that's interesting okay I I
personally have not had a bad reaction
the most common reaction is
silence right like it it's in your spam
folder they don't have time to respond
to you they're not interested or they're
too shy to quite frankly like a lot of
us are shy to talk to people online um
so to give people the benefit of Doubt
uh they they don't know how to help you
um uh the the the second part of the
question talking about the possibility
of coming office
entitled
um I think it well it depends how you
phras things right like it comes across
in your tone um do you demonstrate like
humility it's not that you're saying hey
I need you to read this it's uh by the
way like I've actually done my homework
I don't want to waste your time in a
call I'm not asking you about Basics um
and there might be mutual benefit here
to us
talking that that I think that's what
that that that's the kind of signal that
it is sending to other people people um
and it's giving people a chance to say
yes to you with more information than
just a LinkedIn request um so many of us
get like
spam that we don't know what's a
legitimate request and what's not
legitimate you know so having a an
actual crafted message that's not please
can we have a call please can you refer
me um should increase your success rate
some
degree
uh okay so the question is
answered yes thank thanks for that um
any any other questions or ways I can
help
folks
uh do you have any more
questions thanks dear
Elliot hi is it Aaron yes yes I'm Aon uh
thank you very much H thank you very
much for your presentation I would like
to give you some questions if you may
sure uh so I would like to ask you
questions about uh connecting AC Academy
to
Industry uh how to be flexible and
connect your research to Industrial
Research in data science especially in
the field of artificial intelligence and
cross-disciplinary artificial
intelligence
specifications great question uh um so
I'm assuming that you're asking like say
you've done a very specific project in
the past maybe more theoretical even
exactly how do you sell that to Industry
when you're
applying H or how do you tailor both
your theory yes to the industry exactly
okay um I'm thinking like the easiest
way to do that is so so when you're
applying for a job right the the
employer trying to figure out things the
first thing is do you actually know the
domain that you're applying to in this
specific industry like say Healthcare AI
Health specifically ai ai bioinformatics
ai chem informatics I have a bachelor's
degree in chemistry and Masters I'm
doing my masters in um computer and
information science but I'm interested
in doing artificial intelligence PhD so
uh I would like to not just um specify
in one Nisha thing thing and go right
into acade Academy and uh get far from
industry I would like to get to know
both businesses both Industries uh both
Fields very well both Academy and
Industry okay so are you like in the
context of writing there are you
thinking like how do you combine that in
yes how how how can I be smart and
flexible to uh not lose my interest
while doing my research at the Academy
and also do uh be flexible enough uh to
be able to sell that research to the
industry and find uh tailored customers
to my
research okay um I have two thoughts so
the first is that it never never never
hurts to go deep and like if you are
very strong academically and
theoretically um that is probably the
edge that you'll have over other
candidates for the same job so
definitely like continue to embrace that
don't don't Fe don't like you know fear
that it'll hurt your industry chances uh
but the way you then uh sell yourself to
Industry will have to look very
different right you're you're you can't
send them a PDF of your research
articles that you've done in undergrad
like your thesis papers for example um a
lot of times they won't have time to
understand why this finding translates
to their bottom line
um so in again like in the constraints
of a thousand-word article or even less
thousand word block posts um you want to
Signal domain knowledge right like
you're you're you're in BIO
informatics and you want to get into
bioinformatics for example like
absolutely signal that you have this
information and knowledge down cold
right you're not just some newbie trying
to break in um you did lots of school
for this right so this could be in the
like the introduction section of the
article right um You signal all the
domain context specific stuff you need
to know and then in the methodology
section also that comes into play again
and that's where you can really show
that you thought of all the edge cases
that someone without context would not
think about if they were trying it for
the first
time
um yeah I think like I don't think it
should be a constraint in that way it
should only make you better the question
then is how exactly how you sell it
right like yes yes yeah it's got be a
tight article yeah uh because it
sometimes bothers me that um so recently
I noticed that uh it's been eight years
that I have been considering getting a
PhD because um I'm 23 years old so just
a year ago I finished my bachelors and
currently I'm doing my Masters uh and
it's been eight years since I was
wondering should I uh go deep into
science or should I just uh stay tailor
to my um country local industry uh
but uh
I'm it seems like I'm losing my fear to
be lose B boundaries become Limitless
and become uh and do my PhD road so um
of course I would like to uh thank you
that was very very very informative that
one should never uh hold back if has a
nich understanding of a field and wants
to break in um and especially when uh
you know you have done a lot of time
research on like chemistry and now
you're doing AI yeah yeah yes and uh may
I ask you for uh also advice
about cross
disciplinary uh professions and Sciences
uh according to AI like bioinformatics
and AI chemistry and AI how is the
industry responding to this cross
disciplinary uh developments of
professions wow okay um I definitely
can't speak to that specifically but I
can I can speak to it on a general
career advice
level um so so I've realized that the
industry is actually quite small um and
it's hard to find Talent which
is hard it's difficult to understand
this when you're applying to jobs with
like a thousand applicants right and
you're like why am I not why am I not
getting through the interviews why am I
not getting the job like I'm a good
candidate um it's hard to find people
who have a specific combination of
skills that a company needs at a point
in time and the way to increase your
chances of that is to work on those say
three skills you only need like three
skills to be really above average at
your job so communicating is will help
you in any job for sure if you're a
strong writer and speaker um whether
you're a your salesperson or as an
engineer it will give you an edge uh the
technical depth like are you continuing
to learn on the job like are I know that
a lot of technical work like even if
you've landed like a dream job as an
engineer often times um projects take a
long time to to get started or it fails
it flops it's cancel and you don't have
anything actually to talk about um yes
right we hear a lot about remote jobs
where you're only working like four
hours a day nothing's happening um right
so if you can if you're in one of those
situations could you do a side project
to keep up um and you again you don't
need to do a lot you just need one
really learn the latest tool um in data
a really good tool to learn right now is
DBT and their free courses online to get
started um build your own like full
stack project become like a full stack
data scci scientist it's much easier now
with tools like chat GPT to help you
learn
faster um yeah so you have your your
communication skills and your technical
skills and then the third piece is like
the specific domain knowledge that you
have so then if you have those those
three things like all of a sudden you're
be you're very attractive to an employer
right and they they can understand your
your skill set very
clearly and may I ask this
Elliot I would like to know if uh how do
you respond to this idea uh trying to
build a career starting from somewhere
where it is not very
competitive uh and build your way up to
more competitive
organizations yeah uh it's kind of
similar to the question is it um better
to start at a small company or already a
large company but H I would like to know
how do you respond to this starting your
career your PhD your studed at somewhere
where there is not much compet
competition and you can also take your
time to build some uh professional
skills yeah very good question um I I
think it boils down
to which is the which is the job where
you can get mentorship at and I say this
because I've I have experienced
with enrols where I have really bad
mentorship or no mentorship and I found
that many of those cases it capped my
opportunity to grow um so if you can
think of it from like a coding
perspective how do you become a better
coder you could read blogs and courses
and stuff but it only gets you so far
and watching even having the opportunity
to watch a really good engineer at the
company work through a problem yes
exactly is like it's like worth more
than anything else right like it's worth
more than any course you could find any
boot camp fine and I've like every time
that's happened to me I'm like oh my God
like I I need to learn from this person
I need this person to be my boss I need
to be on this team I need to be in that
company um so I I've been very
conflicted kind of like you on big
company or startups I've only had the
opportunity to work at startups uh for
reasons um but as I've grown through the
roles what I've come to prioritize is
the the boss who the boss is will they
Mentor you is there a path for growth um
and are there other people in the
company that I can learn from if say my
boss is
unavailable
yes so you have also developed um very
good skill of being able
to uh get your thoughts through even
when your boss is not
available like U being able to
communicate
virtually via
email uh even if you don't have
the the chance of doing the face tof
face me it it was very informative I
hadn't considered that watching a senior
developer engineer work looks
like where's than course you can take
yeah no I I I I um I realize this as
someone who's only worked remote as well
right so like there's an additional
barrier if you're not actively talking
to people in slack
channels and you can't walk by someone's
desk and be like hey what you working on
can I can I get your thoughts on
something um finding someone who's
willing to screen share as they work
through something and show you how
things can be done better I'll give you
guys like a super simple example it's
kind of trivial even I was screen
sharing and this engineer was watching
me like guiding me through a
task and um I was just doing a get
commit right to create a pull
request and I was I think I I couldn't
figure out like what all the commits I
had going on and he was like oh just do
get status right because he could see me
struggling and I was like get status I
don't know what get status is I like oh
it's so basic right man this is
embarrassing but just like that I
learned something new um and uh I would
never have stumbled on that if
as a best practice in a workflow if an
engineer hadn't been watching me and so
after the call he said um because I I
said to him like I need to learn better
coding best practices like and I don't
want to keep learning from books because
it's not helpful he said okay we we'll
PA program and you can watch
me yeah so I think finding that person
and an organization who's not shy about
that is willing to take you on it could
be your boss it could be a colleague
like that beats whether it's a big
company or a small company
yes that would be amazing
yeah that would be
amazing so most of the people who uh had
advised me to uh get into research uh
after working for a while uh in the
industry is because when you're doing
research uh you may not have the
professional technical skills of writing
the clean code and maybe the code for
the research is not as clean as you
would stumbl upon it uh in the industry
so industry teaches clean code and uh
that will help uh if I am to help
another person who is new to research
screen sharing screen sharing and
showing how everything is
done by my experience that that that was
a good point that was very good point oh
I I'm happy to pass this on because I
feel like I am learning all of this
accidentally at times I'm like oh right
of course this is not obvious to me um
and I I have I faced some
disadvantages like for example I live in
a small city um that has no tech hisry
there you go right and I I for reason
personal reasons I can't move and I've
been worried about does that limit my
potential in tech oh um right you worry
about that right if you're
country so you think okay what is your
goal here whatever job you're in is that
you want to learn
XYZ you want to form relationships with
colleagues because those are important
networking relationships as you proceed
in your career um which company can best
help you achieve those goals is it like
sometimes you can get a really nice job
at like safe faceebook it pays really
well maybe that's a bad example like a
prestigious job right versus a job where
you know the team you know the working
culture and you know they'll help you
grow it's almost always better to go
with the team and and culture um over
the shiny prestigious job where it's
like ah you might be kind of left on
your own for seven hours a day and then
with no portfolio to speak of at the end
of
it uh and I would not like
um it's a very very good point and um I
would like to ask this uh in advance
how do you identify a toxic environment
uh when you're working remotely uh at a
work
space that's been really tough for me
because I've gone stuck a few times
um yeah you because you cannot really
identify these things in an interview um
process like you can ask them questions
and they can say all the right things
especially in the competitive uh Market
but in the competitive industry or um a
company that is very competitive and
large
yeah it I think it helps if you could
talk to the person who left like why did
they leave is it for a better offer yeah
um if that's then okay um you could talk
to other people on the team to get a
sense of things but even then they may
not be willing to disclose if they're
struggling
to um I found a a way to do this kind of
accidentally because because of my
freelancing I work for multiple
companies and they all work very
differently um but I've been able to
kind of test drive them out before I do
more work and actually one of the
companies that uh I will be joining
full-time next week I chose because for
a month I got to observe how they work
and do I like them um and and how will I
be treated you know um so I don't know
that's not like a typical way to do it
but if you are in
aing yeah and may I ask what were the uh
things that caught your eye in terms of
their uh working skills teamwork yeah
well for me specifically I I I my
strength is not technical I am first and
foremost social science writer right I'm
learning Tech to get into Tech but so
for me the things I looked for were are
the engineer nice to talk to right are
they scary do they like does it when I
talk to them is it does it feel like I'm
wasting their time you know are they
taking the time to explain basic things
to me like the good status example right
um how can I can I see what they're
working on in some capacity whether live
through a call um or they're keeping me
updated
um and recently I found that being
direct about your concerns
actually gets you better
answers so i' because in the past I used
to be kind of afraid of being very
honest about my
fears um because it may signal that oh
I'm not very strong about this but I
think like you know what I don't want to
be in a bad situation again so let me be
direct with you and I said um one of the
things I'm worried about working in a
remote C remote company is that I will
get lost right if you don't talk in the
channels you disappear and I'm shy like
I don't I don't love to talk all day and
in public channels about stuff or ask
for help how would you help me what is
the culture here and then they would say
oh I totally understand um I'm very
approachable we I send memes to my
colleagues all day um stuff like that
and you go like oh okay so like it's not
stuffy in
here dangerous to each other it's
actually kind of friendly and now they
know that I'm shy they'll make more of
an effort to help me
out
it's as I talked to you it's uh it's
such a pleasure and I admire every
single Insight you uh give I would like
to um address this very
um
precise part of your speech that you are
a social scientist and you're trying to
get into Tech yeah and currently it is
very
important uh the human computer
interaction Sciences are very important
and are developing at a very good speed
and u i myself I'm very communicative I
love communicating and and for me um if
I only work by myself I love Theory I
love Science re um getting to know every
single bit of it gives me such a joy but
uh not working with people not seeing
people um it affects me and it doesn't
affect me in any good way so I always
need to communicate um in my workplace
and uh my educational system uh may I
ask
um how this train can be used
communication and not not uh as an
engineer but the combination of those
two would be
magnificent combining social skills and
uh science and computer science uh would
you please um talk further about this
subject yeah oh like the combination of
skills um and
also and also how one can uh put it into
good use maybe do something new with it
not
just about communicating and networking
which is hugely impacting impacting
one's professional life um but uh also
um maybe some of us have very good
social skills and are trying to force
ourselves to get into Tech and do
technical stuff but we shouldn't ignore
our strengths
either
great no great question um I will say
that um I always try to sell writing to
technical folks because I know that
technical books don't like to write uh
but the best Engineers are very strong
writers and you see this in companies
and you also see it online like some of
the most influential like CEOs uh are
technical Founders right and they are
able to be project their Charisma online
uh one of the one of the companies I
work for you know they have a Twitter
account they have a marketing team that
handles it they push blog posts the
tweets that do the best are the ones
where the CEO starts to say here are the
10 best practices on database principles
that I think are unpopular but I believe
in and he goes into like super technical
detail like he like whoa where dides
this come from right uh this is like
information that's not easy to get and a
CEO is talking directly to people about
so definitely don't un underestimate the
value of like being great at
both
um and in terms of like getting better I
find that like it's it's kind of like
any other skills like you got to
practice so now that Co is largely over
it try to go to inperson conferences and
speaking specifically to like you and I
where we are smaller cities it sounds
like where there's not a tech Hub if
possible go to the the closest city
where there is one right whether for a
day trip or something go to that
conference get a sense of like what the
people are like make friends in the
industry um and even if it's not you
don't feel like it's a meaningful
connection just add them on LinkedIn
they they'll be posting things about
jobs and stuff that might be relevant to
you one day um and it's a good way to
practice pitching yourself over and over
again to strangers right every new
connection you make you have to talk
about the same thing who you are what
you studied and where do you want to go
um and learning how to be curious about
another person yeah you can do this
online too uh but I just find that like
you got to have that balance and
especially like if you're in a smaller
City with no Tech Hub it like really
pays to like go out once in a while to
another
city yeah I hope that's helpful I'm I'm
trying to keep my uh answers as broadly
applicable as possible yes yes whatever
yeah industry yeah
I do live in a city uh which is trying
to become a techup but isn't currently
so
uh it was a very good point trying to
travel around and uh see other people in
different
cities um yeah thank you very much for
your responses for for your reply uh for
your answers also explanations they were
very precise and generalized and also
they very Nisha
answers uh I highly admire your
enthusiasm for this uh kind of work that
you did today thank you very much no I I
appreciate your kind words very much and
there's been great questions from the
audience um and yeah I just hope to give
back in some way that you know many
people have helped me out with um so
yeah definitely like you're you're
you're doing the right thing by being
here um and uh it can only be exciting
things
head yes in
Tech yeah are there are there any other
questions I I don't want to take up too
much time
um let's see okay all right so we are we
have 15 minutes left
um yeah again if you're too shy to ask a
question in the group feel free to just
book a call you can get into it